mais pour démarrer Florent les salariés
du pôle santé Vinc à chambr et les tours
en grève une grève qui fera date ou
premier mouvement social dans l'histoire
de la clinique hein c'est dire si
l'inquiétude est grande en cause des
effectifs réduits à pot de chagrin selon
les manifestant avec en toile de fond la
revente programmée de l'établissement
prévu jusqu'à jeudi l'impact de cette
grève reste limité du fait des
réquisitions de soignants mais les
syndicats veulent maintenir la pression
sur le futur propriétaire
Romainville
soignign de mémoire de soignant c'est la
première grve du personnel au pôul santé
Léonard de Vincy a chambré les tours ça
fait 30 ans que je travaille ça fera 30
ans l'année prochaine et j'ai vu
vraiment le métier se dégrader en fait
les conditions de travail se dégrader en
fait quand j'ai commencé ce travail en
fait j'étais presque fier de le faire
aujourd'hui je viens presque à reculon
chaque jour en fait pourquoi parce que
le le le nombre de personnes chaque jour
est diminué là encore récemment on nous
parle d'une personne en fait d'une aide
soignante et d'une infirmière pour 15
patients actuellement orthopédie
ingérable un constat partagé par toutes
celles et tous ceux qui se sont
rassemblés devant la clinique
détérioration des conditions de travail
et sentiment d'abandon de la part de la
hiérarchie les salariés sont en pression
il y a une charge de travail une
incompréhension quand ils se plignent
REM des informations donc ça peut plus
durer pour ces salariés le contexte de
revente prochaine du pôle n'est sans
doute pas étranger aux conditions de
travail dégradé car moins de salariés
c'est moins de masse salariale et un
meilleur résultat net propice à une
vente dans les meilleures conditions la
variable de justement souvent c'est le
personnel et donc avec donc un recours
au remplaçant aux volantes au vacatair
de plus en plus fréquent puisque de plus
en plus des collègues bah sont sont en
AR maladie la grève est programmée pour
durer jusqu'à jeudi midi les
interventions programmées le matin sont
reportées les
après-midis